Who is the god
like Yahweh the god
of wrath the god of Mercy The God
Who reaches down to unworthy people.
Well, happy Sunday church. My name is John. If
I haven't met you yet. Please come meet me. I'd love to meet you and I see
as a privilege and a blessing to get to preach
most every week as one way to serve the church this
fall. We are walking through the Old Testament prophet Micah
that his book is called
Micah and so you go and find that if you haven't yet,
but we are gonna be in the first few verses of chapter
4 of my cuff Micah for
first five verses as we get into it today though. I want
to tell you about something I read about last week an angle
can Bishop in Mozambique. His name
is Dennis singulane.
And he was at the Forefront of bringing their Civil War to an
end back in 1992.
Now at the end of the war the UN was supposed to disarm both
sides.
But most of the weapons actually remained hidden.
Because people were afraid the conflict was start again, or they
were afraid of prosecution if they gave their weapons over
so it most in the remained hidden. So what Dennis
and the Christian counsel of
Mozambique what they did to resolve this continuing
tension.
Was they initiated What's called the transforming arms
into tools project?
This program advocated the return of weapons which
are tools of death, right?
Advocated return of weapons in exchange for sewing machines
and garden implements and bikes
and construction materials.
Tools of life, right?
And one example of Village turned over all of their weapons in
exchange for a tractor so they could Farm more easily.
In fact, nearly one million weapons were
exchanged in the first 10 years of this program.
You're asking the question what happens to the weapons though?
Well, they are cut up and the pieces are handed
over to a group of artists.
Who turn them into sculptures and bed frames
and chairs and tables and all kinds
of different things.
In fact a tree of life made out of
ak-47's pistols and rocket propelled grenade launchers
became the new symbol of peace.
Pretty amazing, right like this is what happened in
Mozambique. But here's what we're going to see today in Micah
4.
That's what the kingdom of God does.
The kingdom of God brings a great reversal.
We're going to see that very clearly today that the kingdom of
God brings a great reversal in so
many ways in our lives and Society.
It's been said that God is a god of a world upside down.
He just basically as a god of surprises a god
of the unexpected. He flips things on its head. He does things
the way the world doesn't it's completely different.
It's a great reversal.
Because remember where we've come so far in Micah.
As God's people turned their backs on God
and His Covenant. He was judging them
by allowing destruction to come from outside forces.
And the reason was because the people and even the leaders of the
people were idolatrous. They were greedy. They were oppressing
the poor.
And worst of all they didn't believe God's true character.
which led then of course as we saw last week to the
end of chapter 3 verse 12
all of that led to
therefore Because of You Zion that Hill
shall be plowed as a field.
Jerusalem that City on that Hill shall become
a heap of ruins
And the mountain of the house house of the Lord a
wooded height as if it didn't even exist.
And it seems tragic.
Seems like all hope is lost. This is the end. This is
certainly how things are going to go, right?
but
not all hope is lost.
Because what Micah does next is he inserts a
reversal?
He gives this vision of the future.
That was intended to cause God's faithful Remnant
to Stand Fast and what they were facing.
That God has said this is what's
coming. The threat of of judgment is coming.
But if you believe in him if you still hold on to him
then stand fast because this is
coming.
For them back, then this would have been encouragement help and hope
right?
But I think we'll see even for us today that there is a hope that
we should have to be able to stand fast whenever we Face
trials as well.
So we're going to look first at these reversals In
this passage. I'm going to see five of
them.
I'm going to read through Chapter 4 verses 1 through 5 to see
where we're going. But again remember this is
immediately after verse 12 of chapter 3
where he said this is all going to be destroyed.
Verse 1 of chapter 4. He says it
shall come to pass in the latter days that
the mountain the mountain you just talked about being destroyed the
mountain of the house of the Lord shall be established as the highest of
the mountains.
It should be lifted up above the hills and peoples shall
flow to it.
And many nations shall come and say come
let us go up to the mountain of the Lord to the house of the god
of Jacob that he may teach us his ways that we
may walk in his paths.
For out of Zion shall go forth the law and the word of the
Lord from Jerusalem.
He shall judge between many people's so decide disputes
for strong Nations far away.
And they shall beat their swords into plowshares and
their Spears into pruning hooks. Those
are garden tools.
Nation shall not lift up sword against Nation neither
shall they even learn War anymore, but they shall sit
every man under his Vine and under his fig tree and no
one shall make them afraid.
For the mouth of the Lord of hosts has spoken.
For all the people's walk each in the name of its God, but
we will walk in the name of the Lord
Our God forever and ever.
Now before we dig into this past you need to clarify what he's even talking about here.
Because remember Micah was talking to a specific group
of people about 2,700 years ago who were
facing specific threats and needed specific. Hope
it's a whole book, right? It's all too someone
there. So for them as their hearing
this this surely in verse one the latter days that surely was
future, right it was long from now. We
know this is coming.
Anytime by the way, the prophets use that term latter days or
that day. It's referring to this kind of
indefinite time future that surrounded
the Lord's return the Messiah coming
and this this Kingdom and so they they saw that as that day
out there.
And so they had this perspective that this is surely future. But
we now know as we read through further in
God's word. We progressively get more information
about what was predicted here and in
all the other prophets.
And so what they're talking about is yes a location because it
has to happen somewhere has to start somewhere. So talking about
this location of a mountain and Jerusalem and those kind of things but
as they talked about it, they were more Kingdom focused
than they were location-focused.
Again, it matters but but they focus primarily on the
spiritual implications of that Kingdom that
was coming.
Like they're talking future as if it's gonna happen someday, but
here's what's going to happen whenever it does.
That's their priority here.
And so they talk about in such a way that we can glean the
spiritual insights from and of what's coming
for us as well. But we also then need to lay
on top of it something we call the already but
not yet nature of God's Kingdom.
So for them, it was pretty much all future right, but but
we think now we can look and see elements of
this have already happened in some ways. They're
already some truth to these pieces and you look at the rest of the prophets.
You can see already. Some of it has come but
not all of it yet.
That there's still a future element to
this Kingdom that's described here,
right?
So it's a little bit of confusion that we walk through this. What is
the kingdom of God? Who is it now or is it future? Well, yes.
Both now and already not yet.
So I'll explain more kind of how that plays out as we
go through this a little bit, but that's just so you get a an overview of
of really this prophecy and how we handle
that going forward.
But first again, we're going to look at the reversals. We see here as
we look at this Kingdom that is coming that is
already here in some ways. How does this reverse
things in the world? Look at it in Micah
4 first
Reversal is that the mountain that was once destroyed in
the kingdom is now restored.
The mountain that was once destroyed we see here
is now going to be restored that's talking about
Mount Zion that we just referenced at the end of chapter 3 Jerusalem's
Hill.
Right, that's where all of that the centerpiece
of history for Israel
was that but now after it had been
destroyed is prophesied to be destroyed and we see
later in history that it was.
At some point Micah says that it would go back to being the most
important Hill the highest over all
of the others.
It would regain prominence, but then there's also this idea
of the mountain was the place where God physically dwelled in his Temple
there on that mountain his people would come to worship him
from all over to come to Jerusalem. That
was where it was and now it's destroyed.
He removed his presence due to their sin do
their false worship. He said no, I I'm not dwelling there anymore.
But here now we see he would restore
that Worship On The Mountain again.
His perfect pattern according to the temple in heaven, he
would restore it here in this location. And so
when we we read that and we understand we say
clearly that hasn't happened yet, right?
So we even us are looking forward to something
like they were.
Here's what we're looking forward to.
To something that the New Testament calls the New
Jerusalem on this mountain.
Which will again be the most important city the
most important mountain in all of creation. That's what
he is restoring again. It's it's something
that Micah's faithful Remnant would have
needed to hear in the moment the hope that that brings right
that there's they're pressing in all of the destruction was
coming. They're like is this mountain is this hill gonna be destroyed like
God promises it might but
hope coming.
This is all going to be restored one day.
So hang on.
So that's the first reversal is that this destroyed mountain
now is restored second.
Similarly that Temple that was
on that mountain and will be again was that was once local
now, it will be Global in
the kingdom of God.
The temple that was once local now global.
Notice at the end of verse 1 it says people's shall flow
to it.
This also gets to an illustration right guys does
does water flow uphill?
No, so the image is like the streams flowing
uphill.
The streams of water the streams of people, but that's the
the reversal ideas that streams will flow up
to the mountain people verse 2
says many nations shall come.
To God's house. It says the house of the Lord to
learn and Obey what God says about himself and about
how to live that's what the streams are going towards because
remember this.
The temple was local before.
Like the Jews even Judah itself
saw it kind of like an exclusive club that we've got the temple here.
We've got the location the presence of God lives here and
we're gonna hinder people from fully worshiping Gentiles.
You stay out there. We're gonna come in here. We can come to God,
but nobody else really can in that sense, but
now
in the kingdom of God as the kingdom comes
versus one and two actually use some words in the
Hebrew language.
For people and Nations. It's it's
not talking about geopolitical countries
with a border.
Those words mean it's talking about families. It's
talking about ethnicities what we say are
people groups.
Distinct cultures and languages and and demographics
that that are are very different from
somebody who even lives 10 miles away from them. That's a people
group a family a clan you might say and so
when it says all of these nations are flowing to
this new city, it means this is a global
Temple now,
Not just local. It's got a global
idea. It's the same thing that John in Revelation.
He looked into heaven God gave
him this vision of what this Kingdom will
look like in the end. It's Revelation 7:9 and 10. He
says Behold a great multitude that no one
could number from every nation. That's that word
again from all tribes and peoples and languages standing Before
the Throne before the lamb clothed in white robes with
palm branches in their hands. They're worshiping him crying
out with a loud voice salvation Belongs To Our God
who sits on the throne and to the lamb
They're worshiping Jesus.
This is a global temple in the kingdom of
God.
Here's another reversal number three.
This Micah four Kingdom shows us
that laws once shunned now
desired.
The laws that once were shunned turned away
kicked to the side now are desired.
Again, all these people are flowing Upstream
to come to the temple to do what?
They're coming to hear it says.
Right verse 2 that he may teach us his ways and
that we may walk in his past for out of Zion shall
go forth. The law the word of the Lord from Jerusalem. They're coming
to hear the word of God.
And remember these are these foreign Nations who were
once opposed to anything Yahweh.
Right. In fact, they they mocked the true worship of Yahweh. They
had their own ways of living. They had their own ways of of worshiping.
They thought it was silly. Like why would you ever follow like don't you want
to eat bacon? I mean, come on, like why would you ever want to follow this guy? He's
telling you these things and they're saying all of
this until this point when the kingdom comes
and now it flips and all the sudden they want to hear.
And not just they want to hear they want to obey what God
has said about himself and how life works.
That's foreigners coming for that but even God's Own
people.
Because we've got a pretty negative picture of God's people so far
in Micah, right?
They've turned their backs on his Covenant laws and
his Commandments and they said no, I'm gonna do it my own way now instead
of that in the kingdom of God when the kingdom fully comes.
We see Ezekiel 36 verses 25
through 27 come to pass where God says,
I'll sprinkle clean water on you I will make you
clean from all your uncleannesses from all your Idols. I
will cleanse you I will give you a new heart and a
new spirit. I'll put within you. I'll remove Your Heart of Stone from
your flesh give you a heart of Flesh.
And I will put my spirit within you.
And cause you to walk in my statutes
and be careful to obey my rules.
That's what happens when the kingdom of God Reigns
in someone's life.
Not only foreigners seeing the value of
God's word.
But his formerly rebellious people.
The ones who have their whole lives turn their backs
on him will begin to align more with
What God Says is, right?
So what happens when the kingdom of God comes it's a great reversal?
the fourth one here
And this one shows what God's word does in the life and in
a society?
The fourth Kingdom reversal is the wars that were once raging
now are absent.
Those Wars that were raging at the
time that for a history in the
kingdom of God.
Fully Are Not absent are absent.
And we see it again in Micah 4 look at verses 3 and 4.
He shall judge between many people shall decide disputes for
strong Nations far away. They shall beat their swords into
plowshares. And there's Spears into
pruning hooks. Again. That's the garden implements Nation shall not
lift up sword against Nation. Neither. Shall they learn War anymore, but
they shall sit every man under his Vine under his fig tree
and no one shall make them afraid for the mouth of the Lord of host has
spoken.
So remember who Micah's talking to right now in this setting he's
saying these things most likely to
the remnant left with King Hezekiah as the
Assyrians were closing in on Jerusalem.
They'd already taken a lot of the land around them. And now
they're all holed up in Jerusalem. The Assyrians are right
on the outside and they're ready to destroy that City, too.
and so these people
Micah's audience could hear the Spears
and the swords clanging around outside
the wall. Just ready to come overtake them
like they're gonna they're gonna lead to death and
sorrow and pain where is any hope like is it
always gonna be this way?
You know, they're sitting there thinking God is this is this what the
end is for us? Is this how it's gonna be?
Well Micah speaks for God and says no.
This is not how it will always be.
There's coming a day when things will be different. All the conflict will now
be gone in the kingdom of God because everything's going to be decided rightly.
According to God's word. Everybody's gonna be living according to God's
word. There will be no more conflict. In fact, all of the
the war games like you won't have to go to West Point anymore
to learn more because there's not even more
It's all gone. And in fact, like we saw in
Mozambique all the weapons will be turned into garden tools. Imagine
raking with like a grenade launcher or
something. Like that's what it's gonna happen.
Okay, so
So what will people do?
If we can't debate on Facebook anymore, if
we can't create Wars like what are people going to do all day?
Well, it says it right here.
Gonna sit under their Vines and fig trees.
Which we're like what what does that even mean? Okay. Well, it's an illustration for for
peace and prosperity.
Where it means like there's no threat.
If you got no problems, no issues. No one worried that
somebody's going to come take there's nothing threatening around.
I came I had this image as I was reading that last
week like you you imagine them.
What he's talking about here you imagine them spreading
out like a picnic blanket under this tree and they
got some peanut butter and fig jelly sandwiches and
they're got a nice little glass of grape juice to wash it down with and
they're just enjoying the Cool Breeze and hanging out having a great
time. Like that's the image.
And we're all like that's kind of funny. But no we all want that don't we?
We're all looking forward to fall whenever the weather turns and we can actually sit outside
and not sweat all day. Like that's what we want. We want this.
Even unbelievers want this, right?
In fact, this is for so Micah writes this Isaiah writes
a very similar passage. It's an Isaiah
chapter 2 that passage from Isaiah 2 is on the wall outside
of the United Nations.
This turning swords into plowshares and Spears and
pretty good. That's what their Desiring too.
So what the world is created we have this innate desire
in us for peace for Comfort. We know this is wrong conflict
and War we know it's bad like just think
of every Beauty whatever they call scholarship pageants now,
I don't know but like it's every answer to
the the one question. What's your greatest world world peace, right.
That's what I want World Peace.
It's in US.
It's it's there because we know there's something
better out there.
And we work for it. We work for it. The problem is.
It doesn't work, right.
We still fight all the time about stuff. They're still Wars going
on all the time. There's it's it's because the sin inside of
us.
It's there.
But Micah 4 says it doesn't have to be that way and one day it's not going to
be that way. But here's the only reason it's possible.
because in verse
4 he says
the Lord of hosts has spoken.
see that
because the Lord of hosts has spoken.
Now that word hosts refers to the armies
of angels in heaven.
And there are Allegiance upon Legions. We don't even know how many
angels there are in God's Army, but he
fully controls them which means
no earthly. Army could stand a chance
against God's Heavenly Army.
The Lord of hosts has said here's how
this is going to go. And so nobody stands any chance. That's why
there's peace.
When God's kingdom fully comes because God the king is
fully in charge at that point.
Nobody has any say there's no conflict because
it's one way and this is how it's going to go.
And it's the best way because he designed it that way.
That's coming.
That's coming the kingdom of God as it comes one
day fully will come and there's no conflict anymore.
No more family strife.
No more invasions of countries none of that.
It will all be resolved.
But we're not there yet, right.
so until that time comes
until that day
We know that the more God comes to
reign in people's lives.
The more life looks like this picture of
Peace in Micah 4.
Right, the more god reigns in
you the more peace making you will be.
This is coming to bear as the kingdom comes in you.
This should come more out of you.
It's a reversal.
Where we once fought over everything now, peace.
Here's the final reversal it's in verse 5 a
little more hidden but it's kind of a call to action you'll see it look
at verse 5 again.
Says for all the people's walk each in the name of its God, but
we will walk in the name of the Lord Our God forever and
ever.
So here's the reversal as I see it here.
people that were once oppressed
now Victorious
the people that were once oppressed
because again remember the context of Micah 4
People all around them.
Were submitting to their own little G
Gods gods that are not really Gods right? They were finding all
these different Idols to worship. All these different gods to follow all
of them were submitting to their own Gods and
not only that they were mocking Judah as
they worshiped the one true God and so
Micah ends in verse 5 by saying
their gods aren't actually going to last.
You see that?
They walk in these but we walk in the name of our God
forever and ever they walk temporarily it might work
for a little while, but forever and ever our
god reigns. We as God's people
will walk in the name of Yahweh Our God forever and
ever.
That's what he means here.
He's saying to us. This is what he's saying to them saying to us.
This is what you need to see is that there's one true God
and he is Yahweh.
And so for those in that moment who were once oppressed by
all the unbelievers around them now they look
at this and they're shown to be victorious over all the
other false religion.
That they know they're about to be attacked. They're about to be overtaken, but
they know one day they're on the right side of history in
this thing.
You always God. He's the one we're going to cling to him. No matter
what a truth which should lead them and lead us to
remain faithful instead fast every day.
Because he is God.
And he's Victorious.
So you see these reversals, right? So the kingdom of
God does as kingdom comes in our lives comes in society. It comes
once and for all someday it brings a great reversal and
how the world Works how the how the Lord cares for
his people how he desires worship to occur. This is what he does
as he brings his kingdom.
So the question is what do we do with this?
What do we do with this passage? Again? Michael was speaking to them,
but he said since speaking to us. What do we do? How does it apply to
us both now and in the future, how do we do what we
need to do with this? We saw what it meant for them.
We see glimpses of what it's going to mean for us someday.
What about today? How do we apply it?
How we encouraged by it how we challenge by this?
What are some simple ways we can step forward in this?
Well first here's the
The thing we know for certain in response to
this.
Is like Micah called them to do we must also look to
the king.
first and foremost
we must look to the king.
She really clear throughout this passage is the reality that
there is a king and his name is Yahweh.
There's no other option.
And and no other God as it says in verse 5
know that God can sustain. No the God can last no
other God will prove worthy. This is him and
him alone and he's gonna restore all things to his way.
And what's going to happen someday is
that all human kind will respond one way
or the other when God shows himself
as the king.
It's best to go ahead and acknowledge Him as king now.
Let me just give you a warning for that don't want to wait till
that day. And then decide you need to acknowledge Him as King
in your life today.
Because this Lord of hosts.
is the one who brings peace in our lives he
is our peace scripture says
And the way he brings peace.
Which the the number one need for
peace we have is in his relationship with
him. That's peace. Number one. The only way he brings peace
in that way is ultimately through the life death and resurrection
of Jesus in our place.
And so it counts vertically first.
Things that that Micah's audience would have only known a
hint of we now know the greatest need
we have like they couldn't walk up the hill themselves right who
can Ascend who separated from us, they couldn't make
it and so they knew they needed something. We now know who
that is that something that someone is Jesus
God In the Flesh who lived the perfect life we could never
live died to death. We deserve and defeated sin and death
once and for all in his resurrection. That is
the way we have peace with God.
The only way you can be a part of this delivered City
someday.
Like if you want this Micah for picture in your
life you turn from your sin turn from yourself turn to Jesus.
You confess with your mouth that Jesus is your king and you
believe in your heart that God did raise him from the dead and
you will be saved you'll be included in this
city forever.
But listen, that's
I know there's a lot of effort given in the world towards self-help and
correction and trying to be better at a person and okay great.
But that is when the
Great reverse will begins in your life.
See what happens then is you say God, you're my
king and his kingdom starts to reign in your life.
His kingship is in charge of your heart
as you Shuffle down off the Throne of your heart and let
him sit rightly in his place on that Throne. That's when
the reversal happens in your life.
things begin to change so you start by looking to
the king not just by glancing up at him and knowing he's there but by
looking to him in faith and trust
That's what we're talking about.
Because when you do that.
As you look more fully to the king you will
naturally then live for the king.
You look to the king.
You will then begin to live for the king.
That's one of the main themes this passage.
It's the word walk or the word come. It's the same word in
the original language used a little bit differently.
Walk walk come come which which illustrates how
important one's lifestyle is here, right?
Because these people want to walk in his paths that
means live not just walk a certain Road. It's
to live in a certain way verse 5 even
says that there are multiple options.
of who you walk in the name of
You see that right? He says you you represent something
someone as you live your
life.
Kind of we're in football season now, so kind of thinking like you're wearing
someone's Jersey as you live your life.
So you have one option which is to wear the jersey of any
other false god or idle or
thing. You're living for that that you live your life having their
logo on your chest.
That you are representing them you are living for the
name of this entity.
That's one option.
The other and better and Lasting option
is to where yahweh's Jersey?
To walk in the name of Yahweh having his
logo on your chest in Revelation says on your forehead, right?
It's gonna be there where you represent him to
the world as you live your life.
And again, we're not just talking about after Jesus returns and
the kingdoms fully inaugurated. We're talking about putting that Jersey on now and
wearing it and representing him even today as the
kingdom reorients our hearts and lives towards him and
his ways.
Because remember this the kingdom of God the way we
live in the Kingdom will often look upside down to
the world around us.
That's the whole point of why we studied The Parables this
summer.
Because they're about the kingdom and their their whole
point is to show us that the kingdom of God works completely
backwards to the way the world sometimes.
often
and so he's saying to us as Jesus told the Parables he's saying reorient your
life reset your life around the kingdom principles
that I have because it's gonna look different than the way of
the world and the way your heart and flesh really want to go in sense.
Now, you've got to you've got to think differently. You got
a reverse this thing to live for the kingdom of
God.
I read it this way this week our lifestyles.
Are meant to be a sign of the
future in the present.
The kingdom coming in our lives
today is meant to show what the Kingdom looks like fully one
day.
To reflect it to show it to the logo of
the Kingdom on our chest to say here's what it looks like.
Here's the way you can trust. It looks.
So there's a lifestyle difference. Here's another part of applying
this today.
We saw here that the Nations will one
day desire to hear God's word, right? They're going
to stream to this new Temple. So why don't
we go ahead and get a jump start on this thing and start carrying God's word
to people today.
Locally here your neighbors your coworkers fellow students.
You you carry the word of God to them globally to
people who don't have a chance to hear. We carry God's word to them that's
gonna happen in the Kingdom. So let's start doing it now.
Another thing we see here. If one day that they're
in the Kingdom fully coming. If one day there's going to
be peace on Earth Goodwill toward men Merry Christmas,
right if that's going to come someday.
Then we should seek to bring about that peace that Shalom
the Old Testament says even today.
Be peacemakers even today to live Fair lives
with people.
This is Kingdom stuff to seek Justice by lining everything with
God's Right Way in his word to stop coveting to
avoid strife and bitterness to take no revenge over
people to only speak words that build up not tear down.
This is being a peacemaker that Jesus said in Matthew
5:9 blessed are the peacemakers.
For they shall be called sons of God.
Logo on your chest designated as something based
on your peacemaking.
It's a lifestyle shift to bring about the kingdom of God into day-to-day
life. This is living for the king.
See we often talk about in church like the future hope
that we have an absolutely we do that one day when God's
kingdom fully comes. It's all gonna be perfect again like
the Garden of Eden was
Where there's no more dementia, there's no more Strife. There's
no more cancer and none of that's even existing
anymore. It's going to be one day.
absolutely, we hold on to that but
you and I as Believers have a
foretaste of that Kingdom in us already.
Kingdom God's Reign and Rule one day
fully right now in your life
Through you in you working out
his Rule and Reign. So we should
then work out those principles Even
in our daily lives today.
It's what Jesus prayed to his father in Matthew 6:10. He
says your kingdom come your will
be done on Earth as it already is in heaven.
He basically prayed God let us help us
live out your kingdom as a perfectly
is up there and one day will be let us
live it out here today.
Your will be done on Earth as it is in heaven your kingdom
come that's the goal.
Because when we talk about the future like we always do about
how hopeful it's going to be and we celebrate in clap. What
the the No More Pain No, More Death all of that. We love that
and we clap for that and we wait for that but you got
to hear me waiting is not passive.
Waiting is active.
Like we have to think waiting. We just kind of sit on the couch and veg
out and hope it comes someday, you know waiting is an active principle,
which is how second Peter 3 describes it by the
way second Peter 3 verses 11 through 14. He says
in light of this latter days that is coming
in light of the Kingdom coming someday. He says since
all these things are to be dissolved what sort
of people ought you to be.
in lives of Holiness and godliness
Waiting for and hastening the coming of the
day of God.
He says that day of God's the heavens going to be set on fire
dissolved the heavenly bodies of melt as they burn basically God's gonna hit reset on
entire creation. But according to his promise
we're waiting for new heavens and new earth in which
righteousness dwells.
Therefore check this out therefore beloved since
you are waiting for these things.
Be diligent to be found by him without spot
or blemish.
Waiting is not passive waiting is active and waiting is
a lifestyle difference.
because of what's coming
but here's the struggle in all this.
I'm sure those original hearers when when Micah said this and Micah 4.
He said it to them they struggled with this. I'm sure many of
you me we struggle with this as well because
we look around they for sure. We look around even
today and we see things so far from
God's ideal, right?
The kingdom of God is coming. It's already but
not yet. It's coming and we're looking around like
see much of it.
So what do we do with that?
What should our response be to that?
That lack that we see.
was a lot of things we already seen we can do but one thing for sure is this should
spur in us a deeper longing for the
kingdom of God.
That we should long for this Kingdom
desire want this Kingdom to come.
I guess just spur in us a different heartbeat that
we have a glimpse of it. Yes, but the the best life that
we're gonna live is not now.
The best life is one day coming.
That's what we're hoping. And that's what we know is coming.
That's why we can have hope even the midst of Crisis today
because we know something is fixed on the other
side. I read this definition of hope. I love this. It says
a future trust that the things planned will
be accomplished because the person in charge is able
to make good on the promises that were made.
It's not just hoping that it does actually happen. It's hoping
in those surely going to happen because the
one who made the promise is definitely going to make it happen.
And he's proven himself over and over throughout history.
So Hear Me church, we never have to worry that the
world is somehow out of control
like we use that term a lot don't we like man the world is out of control?
No.
It's not out of control because nothing not disasters
not evil. Not pandemics not a
cancer. Not not any persecution. Nothing
can undo or frustrate the
final goal that God has established.
Now we might not understand it how it all works or how
he's going to take this mess and somehow straighten it
out, but we know he can and we know he will.
As surely as he walked out of that grave on the third
day proves he can do anything and he's
fully in control of even the end the worst thing death.
He's over it.
Which means that one day Church listen one day it will
look like Micah 4.
Where there's a Victorious King reigning over a
delivered city a city that's full of
holy people from All Nations a city
that's full of Peace a city that's full of his glory. That's
what's coming. So, hang on.
So hang on Long want this
reversal that God is bringing about
in your life in the society and one day fully will finish hang on
to him. And as you do as you
trust him be reminded of what he said in Romans 8
of what he is guaranteeing for us. He says
who shall separate us from the love of Christ.
Shall tribulation or distress or persecution or
famine or nakedness or danger or sword? No, in
all these things. We are more than conquerors through
him who loved us.
For I'm sure that neither death hear me, whatever you're
facing right now hear me for I
am sure that neither death nor life nor angels nor
rulers nor things present nor things to
come nor powers nor height nor depth nor
anything else in all creation will be able to separate us
from the love of God in Christ. Jesus our lord.
So long for his kingdom to come
Church long for this reversal look to
your king with faith and trust and
as you look to him, let him change your life. Let
him use you to live for him
as the kingdom comes more today than it ever has so
far.
longing for the day
when it's finished.
As surely as he said on that cross it is finished. He's going
to finish it. All he will complete the work. He started you
Philippians 1:6 guarantee.
So hang on.